ومع استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي على مناطق
عده يضطر السكان الى النزوح مرات عده ايضا
وافاد اهالي منطقه الحكر في دير البلح
بانهم رغم التزامهم بالمناطق الامنه التي
حددتها قوه الاحتلال فانهم يتعرضون
للاستهداف اليومي
لمنازلهم 121 يوم بنزح من مكان لمكان وين
جيش الدفاع بقولنا بنوجه بنوجه على المكان
اللي بقولنا عليه وينظر بالمكان اللي
بقولنا عليه انا كنت قاعد في البيت بيت
نسايبي انضرب بيت اخوهم لساي الساعه 3 الف
بدون سابق انذار لا صاروخ زنانه ولا انذار
ولا اتصال ولا اي حدا بلغنا ما شفنا الا
برميل نزل على البيت بيت من ثلاث طوابق
الصف في طابق واحد طلعنا من الشهداء الحمد
لله على كل حال والاصابات وربنا سلمنا انا
واحد من الناس اربع مرات وين اروح على
مكان يصير الاستهداف للبيت اللي جن اربع
مرات ونا عمر نعيش احنا اهل غزه صامدين
وصابرين وعند الله
محتسب وعند الله تلتقي
الخصو